yeah welcome to this video playing to
national master artists in Poland right
we are from Poland and enemas oh let's
see if we get nope don't get the hoopla
variation step this isolated Queen pawn
line and I have forgotten as usual but
i'm recommending i think i'm
recommending rook e8 Bishop f8 but let's
see me yep of this regrouping some
pretty good idea getting this Bishop on
g7 on dg7 to g7 to m2m to shield to the
king also okay I could I could play
could I play five here now he's got
Bishop g5 coming okay it's weakening but
I don't want Bishop g5 coming
my idea is supply Bishop g7 id-5 really
65 just blasting open the center Bishop
f5 and move like that try to to to
activate all pieces in the center okay
this was the plan anyway yeah you five
is tough now after taking it does d5
hanging instantly so on I need to I need
to strengthen first yeah I what I just
wanted to play be 60 but he prevented
that yeah flight flight once in a while
a German word crimson maybe I am I could
go queen bee 6cm covering the night so
that I can actually be capture with the
Queen and freeing up rook rook dat a
possible move it also puts some pressure
on the form yeah this I didn't expect at
all what's the Queen doing ninety six
maybe
I can I can also consider to take on
neck and I cannot take on default
nonsense sorry the rook is obviously
hanging on the edge okay if I go f5 is
playing night to d6 so not good ok let's
get out of this pin and remove this look
from the sensitive square from this
diagonal aha so I can actually take now
on be too I don't think I can what about
a five though is this is this suicide
could be I could also just take you
three oh come on let's not think eight
for HCM let's just take the rib to just
take this opportunity if he takes you 5
95 probably ok or first take you three
then take you five botha seems possible
95 a text the Queen sopa should be 693
check should be ok I'm threatening now
to take III you take deform but I'm
wondering about a smooth like no this is
not play hmm
hmm maybe it is just good for black
possible but it feels a bit strange this
position I'm not very well developed it
feels like they're there some there's
some disharmony in blacks position like
this night is a bit unstable maybe
there's some syntactic that that is
possible I'd be dope every both um
didn't song didn't see ya now I can they
can grab him to take you five at the
gate now maybe this and take h6 but I've
got two bishops against two nights and a
wide open position this should be it
should be okay at least okay okay I
can't even take here why not
now GF I have Bishop g7 at least taking
his madam but are not better not do that
Queen f6 though could be an idea nap
don't want that let's say let's secure
the king and the rook is still hanging
so others actually really good move
Queen 87 look at King evade the rook is
hanging at the butcher on the night is
saying so maybe he must must know yeah
maybe he must play a queen age for now
yeah I cannot grab because the mate h7
f7 but still filled sound a bit strange
and what about Queenie aid Queen head
covering f7 attacking the other night
maybe I could have played Queen e7
actually queen is why not queee 7
Queenie son was better probably
something attracted me to Queen yet I
don't I don't really know what could I
have bishops III here funny enough 94 94
good lord take you one Knight f6 why why
didn't I play Queenie 7a I'm I didn't
see doesn't see it but after after i
take i'm still mated what the heck
I can play that move though I can he can
give a ton of check son check check
check weenie 5mm also not not winning
amazingly
hmm we had really weird okay let's just
drop back I must have played this really
terribly time morning the stolen made
thread I know it no this is saying and
this is singing can you believe that
check check white forfeits on time what
the game what the heck in this if I if I
just play Queen is heaven instead of
Queen yet am I not just wish I this is
so you cannot believe that now this okay
let's let sets consider isn't this just
winning attacking here attacking here
looked you one okay so Queen takes rook
the eight but I've got this one yeah
this is much better than the game not
sure if it is winning a computer gives
gives about one pawn for black but this
is what I should do creamy aid is really
stupid now ok and now Bishop a six is
stronger because this year he could have
answered with them with this move which
you didn't seem like this one when I
could drop back guarantee a probably
should be content with the draw some
home but I went for this and now I
overlooked 25 yeah i was completely
irritated by not being down yet on 70
seconds yeah yeah tense game but we both
played this really badly at the end
alright thanks for watching